المشهد التاريخي على خير ابطالنا اخيرا
داخل محطه الفضاء الدوليه الحمد لله رائد
وعلى الالتحام بمركبه دراغون المركبه التي
انطلقت بعدم منتصف ليل الاحد نحو الفضاء
من فلوريدا الامريكيه المشهد التاريخي
نشرته الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء عبر تويتر
وقالت ان الثنائي جاهز
للشروع في اداء مهمتهم العلميه لخدمه
البشريه مهمه
وبحثيه المهمه ايضا تشمل ست تجارب على
الدماغ والجهاز العصبي ايضا واربع تجارب
في الخلايا المناعيه والتجارب في
الاستمطار وبيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات